Jak patrzę na prezydenta
który 13. grudnia obiecywał Nam wprost
nie będę przeszkadzał rządowi
będę go wspierał
a na pewno nie będę robił polityki
ustawa okołobudżetowa zawetowana
później
prowadzenie przestępców do pałacu prezydenckiego
następnie
doprowadzenie do sytuacji w polsce niespotykanej
skierowanie budżetu
państwa do trybunału konstytucyjnego
prezydent Andrzej duda
jeżeli chciałby współpracować rządem
to powinien kłaść realne argumenty dotyczące tego
że coś mu się nie podoba
a nie mówić zablokuję pracę wam rządu dlatego
że nie podoba mi się
że nie ma przestępców na sali sejmowej
widział pan kiedyś takie coś